[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on m'indique dans l'été dicks fallait
pas dire bonjour bonjour moi j'aime bien
faire un peu le fou d'entrée de jeu j'ai
une question pour vous répondez dans
votre tête combien vous ne feriez vous
être vis en ce moment sur une échelle de
1 à 10 là maintenant tout de suite sans
réfléchir à l'instinct
j'adore cette question elle nous oblige
à être honnêtes avec nous-mêmes et
regarder les choses en face
maintenant si vous le voulez bien je
vais vous demander de sortir votre
téléphone ça va c'est pas trop difficile
nous en prix à lézinnes
d'ouvrir une conversation avec la
personne dont vous êtes le plus proche
et lui envoyer cette note sans rien dire
et si vous n'avez pas de réseau envoyez
lui ça partira après
pour la suite de l'expérience
je vais et vous allez voir c'est assez
dingue je vais maintenant vous demander
de mettre votre téléphone en mode avion
bon ok j'avoue ça c'est juste pour être
sûr que vous restez attentifs pendant la
suite
bon on va pas se mentir on vit une
époque étrange c'est vrai quand on pense
au futur tout à l'air absolument
merdique il ya 50 ans quand vous
demandez à n'importe qui ce qu'il
imaginait pour les années 2000 2020 tout
le monde vous regardez avec des étoiles
dans les yeux en vous parlant de
voitures volantes d'énergie infinie de
gratte-ciel tellement haut qu'on
enverrait plus le sol nous quand on nous
demande ce qu'on imagine pour le futur
c'est quand même un truc pas ouf à mi
chemin entre walking dead est une espèce
de grand barbecue climatique géant dans
lequel les humains jouent le rôle de la
lune feu nous notre grand projet
collectif de société c'est survivre
vous le sentez qu'on s'est fait
l'un peu ou pas
je m'appelle arthur et j'ai un parcours
bizarre j'ai grandi dans un petit
village de 200 habitants dans les
montagnes à côté jura le genre d'endroit
où en gros soit tu fais du ski soit tu
meurs j'ai choisi d'aller en fac de
sport parce que je savais pas ce que je
voulais faire de ma vie et que comme ça
au moins je pourrai faire du sport en
attendant de savoir ce que je voulais
faire de ma vie il se trouve que pendant
ses études j'ai lancé un média qui
permettait aux gens de raconter leurs
pires anecdotes sexuelle de manière
anonyme vous auriez dû voir la gueule de
ma mère contre toute attente mais
vraiment tout ce média a énormément
grandi à tel point que j'en ai lancé
d'autres sur d'autres thématiques je
vous rassure c'est comme ça que j'ai
créé ma première boîte dans le digital
que j'ai fini par revendre à un groupe
de dating et que je me suis retrouvé
dans une vie entreprenariale
complètement effréné sans trop
comprendre ce qui m'arrivait
alors des fois ça a plutôt bien marché
et des fois ça un peu moins bien marché
comme la fois par exemple où j'ai claqué
tout la trésorerie de ma boîte sur un
coup de tête en oubliant qu'il me
restait 120000 euros de tva à payer
allez lui s'il était devant chez moi
tous les jours j'ai cru qu'ils allaient
ouvrir un camping les mecs mais bon j'ai
fait une fac de sport moi je vous
rappelle
bref pendant toutes ces aventures j'ai
eu l'occasion de me poser beaucoup de
questions sur le fonctionnement de notre
système que je voyais bien de
l'intérieur et sur son impact sur nous
et sur notre monde est un des gros
déclencheur de ces questionnements
c'était la neige enfin plutôt l'absence
de neige chaque hiver je voyais cette
neige pourtant si abondante dans ma
jeunesse disparaître complètement dans
les montagnes natales ça peut paraître
anodin mais moi ça m'a vraiment fait
quelque chose près ce que la plupart des
stations dans lesquelles j'ai appris le
ski et dans lesquels j'ai beaucoup de
mes souvenirs d'enfance ont juste
complètement fermé du jour au lendemain
du coup je me suis intéressé au sujet
est ce que vous savez qu'il y a vingt
mille ans il faisait en moyenne 5 degrés
de moins sur terre à cette époque la
moitié de l'europe était recouverte d'un
glacier de trois kilomètres d'épaisseur
genre 10 fois la tour eiffel en glace le
niveau des océans étaient 130 mètres
plus bas et le sahara il ya encore six
mille ans c'était une forêt tropicale
qui abritait le plus grand lac du monde
tout ce que je veux vous dire là c'est
qu'une variation en moyenne de quelques
degrés seulement ça te fout un bordel
monstrueux et je pense qu'il vous aura
pas échappé qu'en ce moment on est en
train de réchauffer la température
moyenne de la planète comme jamais dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
les scénarios qu'on est en train de
suivre nous emmène quelque part entre +4
et + 7 degrés d'ici la fin du siècle et
ça en gros ça a le pouvoir de mettre fin
à la civilisation humaine et c'est quand
même pas très agréable du coup je me
suis intéressé aux limites de notre
système jusqu'à en faire carrément le
projet de ma vie est très rapidement je
suis arrivé à une conclusion simple
notre système a atteint son seuil de
contre productivité
c'est vrai tous les jours on attend les
mauvaises nouvelles comme si c'était
normal
le climat les pandémies la crise
économique
le mec qui dit chocolatines et forcément
dans un système à bout de souffle bah on
en a plus beaucoup non plus un système
qui rend littéralement le monde
invivable je pense qu'on peut dire qu'il
est devenu contre-productif un système
qui cassent tous les liens des liens
avec les autres les liens avec la nature
les liens avec nous mêmes je pense qu'on
peut dire qu'il est devenu
contre-productif un système qui fait de
nous de simples agents économiques je
sais pas pour vous mais pour moi
clairement il est devenu
contre-productif l'humanité à mieux à
apporter au monde que d'être homo
economicus
ascendant au mot oublie pas la tva us
dont l' intelligence prodigieuse l'a
finalement conduit à travailler en
permanence pour un job dont ils ne
voient pas l'intérêt afin de s'acheter
des trucs dont il n'est pas sûr d'avoir
besoin entre deux burn out on mérite
mieux que ça franchement on mérite
beaucoup mieux que ça et cette période
c'est la parfaite opportunité pour le
prouver parce que vous savez quoi j'ai
une très bonne nouvelle pour vous quand
on est au pied du mur on ne peut que
changer radicalement de direction mon
sofa la limite si on est maçon je suis
d'accord
depuis que je m'implique dans la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique
je côtoie des gens qui pendent des
initiés ti vct extraordinaire et je me
rends compte qu'un changement de
direction massif et hyper excitant a
déjà très largement commencé pour mettre
à jour ce système partout on remet en
question ce qui est censé être la norme
en fait on est en train de passer du
moyen âge à la renaissance c'est juste
qu'on le voit pas encore
chaque jour chaque jour on ne présente
une nouvelle personne qui a quitté un
job hyper rémunérateurs et confortable
juste pour se réaligner et faire un truc
utile c'est tellement violent que plein
de grands groupes n'arrive juste plus à
recruter au quotidien j'ai la chance de
côtoyer des milliers de personnes
littéralement des milliers de tous les
horizons qui investissent leur argent
pour financer et faire émerger de
nouveaux modèles sans attente de retour
sur investissement la pression est
tellement forte que tous les secteurs du
monde sont en train de se réinventer
on dirait les débuts d'internet mais en
mille fois plus gros et les deux acteurs
qui veulent pas changer puisque toujours
un ou deux acteurs qui veulent pas
changer sont crispés mais alors crispé
je vous jure on dire l'épreuve des
poteaux dans koh lanta lennik
alors oui on nous parle de la fin du
monde à peu près tous les trois jours
quand on allume la télé on a
l'impression qu'on a poussé les portes
de l'enfer mais l'humanité fait des
erreurs en avançant et c'est normal les
erreurs c'est justement un des meilleurs
leviers dont on dispose pour retrouver
de l'énergie collectivement et faire
changer un modèle quand ils ne nous
convient plus et c'est précisément ce
qui est en train de se passer la
révolution du sens est en marche et elle
a besoin de nourrir ses rangs à force
d'action et d'optimisme elle a besoin de
nous toutes et tous pour devenir
littéralement inarrêtable maintenant et
chaque individu de plus va faire la
différence c'est la fameuse citation de
margaret mid que vous avez probablement
déjà lu à peu près 300 mille fois sur
les réseaux sociaux mais c'est pas grave
je vais quand même vous la dire ne
doutez jamais qu'un petit nombre
d'individus puisse changer le monde en
réalité c'est toujours ainsi que le
monde a changé
tout à l'heure je vous ai demandé de
faire un truc chelou je vous ai demandé
de noter votre vie sur une échelle de 1
à 10 maintenant j'aimerais vous donner
un hack pour augmenter drastiquement
cette note dans les prochains mois et
vous allez voir ça marche à tous les
coups
à partir de maintenant s'il vous plaît
ne laissez plus jamais personne vous
volez l'espoir refusé cette espèce de
fatalisme ambiant qui nous emmène nulle
part c'est de la merde la meilleure des
façons de perdre c'est de considérer
qu'on a déjà perdu mais on n'a pas perdu
il n'est pas trop tard et nous avons
toujours l'incroyable pouvoir de décider
du monde dans lequel on veut vivre et ça
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est des
dizaines de milliers de scientifiques
partout dans le monde qui ont décidé de
consacrer leur vie à ces questions je
vous invite donc officiellement celui-ci
à rejoindre le côté optimiste de la
force et ça ça veut pas dire être naïf
ou déconnecté de la réalité ça veut pas
dire qu'on s'en fout et qu'on fait comme
s'il n'y avait pas de problème non ça
veut juste dire qu'à partir de
maintenant on refuse tout ce qui n'a pas
de sens et qui nique notre avenir et on
encourage tous qui en a tout le temps
dans tout ce qu'on fait au quotidien
même si on n'est pas irréprochable
personne peut être irréprochable dans un
monde qui n'a lui même pas fait sa
mutation on n'a plus le temps pour les
histoires de légitimité il faut qu'on
avance et on pourra le faire que tous
ensemble
c'est à nous de choisir notre futur et
il est grand temps de le faire c'est à
nous de choisir notre futur et il peut
être beau parce que la fin du monde
franchement c'est chiant
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]